Here's the earth, and here are the sun's rays coming in parallel to strike the earth.
This would be the equation and this line up here would be the tropic of cancer
where the sun's rays are striking the earth perpendicularly.
If I have some 1 m long rod, let's say, here at some latitude north of the Tropic of Cancer,
I can sort of see that there would be a shadow down here cast by the rod.
In fact, I'm going to draw some lines to help guide our eyes.
We know that this angle here is 23.5 degrees,
because this is where the sun's rays are striking vertically.
This angle I'm going to call α and I can tell since this line is parallel to this line
this angle is α as well.
Well, clearly my latitude--I'll call that l--is just equal to 23.5 plus whatever this angle α is.
I just need to find α.
Let's zoom in here, because this is where α is showing up to see if we can figure what's going on.
Here's our object with a height of 1 m and here come the sun's rays,
which makes this the shadow down here.
The shadow also has a length of 1 m.
Now I can see that this angle α is this angle formed by the sun's rays and the object,
so the tangent α is just equal to this opposite side over the adjacent side,
or 1/1, which is just equal to 1.
If I use a calculator to find the inverse tangent of 1,
I find that α is equal to 45 degrees.
Since my latitude is just 45 + 23.5, I have a latitude of 68.5 degrees N.